Nicholas Wawa is busy marking the
borders of his farm outside Nairobi
usually farmers here use wooden posts
for their fences that Nicholas has
bought a new product compared to the
normal the normal post the lifespan of
design is longer than the normal post so
I prefer this one it is reducing the
destruction of our forests it was now
you find we are lesson in the cutting of
the trees in our country so I am for it
because the ecosystem is the new control
on the outskirts of Nairobi the posts
are produced by a new innovative company
eco post is the brainchild of Lorna
Reuter a former banker she came up with
an ingenious way of getting rid of the
city's plastic waste by making
eco-friendly posts from recycled plastic
all this plastic waste has been
collected from various tree dump sites
some streets and even very a home stupid
homes so we bring them here this is the
first step they were flooded from the
track then we store them until we get a
good quantity from there we able to
check them into processing every month
Eco post gives 40 to 50 tons of plastic
waste new life as building material in
its first year of operation it produced
more than 5,000 posts removing hundreds
of tons of plastic waste from the
environment the cash sawdust and we mix
it with a plastic and we make very good
aesthetic and quality posts that can be
used event for now building le as an
alternative to timber so by so doing
able to save a lot of trees and we hope
to save the 2% forest cover that is
remaining in Kenya Kenya has a massive
problem with deforestation much of the
wood is used as building material
eco-post offers not only an alternative
it also removes plastic waste
helps limit toxic pollution something
curran yanira he strongly endorses the
society is part of the problem a problem
in the sense that they are the source of
that waste and they should actually be
responsive on how to dispose of it if
there is a market and that market
generates two three tons every day of
waste plastic then they should I mean
the market should have regulatory
guidelines on how to recycle whatever
that generates then will end up with
less plastics thrown on the streets or
in the landfills every year Kenya's
plastic waste grows almost tenfold lor
Naruto has shown that it's also a
resource which can generate huge profits
eco-post has already created almost 40
full-time positions and hundreds of
casual jobs